[Music] citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for both Andrew and myself inexplicably to both
see superhero movie for the very first time how
you doing today man I'm doing well I'm ready to
finally get to see a masterpiece of Cinema
the holy Grill of the superhero genre in a
year featuring Iron Man and the Dark Knight
one movie shown Supreme superhero movie now
we are going to be watching this for the first
time please leave a comment below one letting us
know how unlikely that is to you cuz we're
we're we're sure it's coming two what your
favorite joke in this movie is because I'm
fascinated especially since this was coming
out right as the end of that era was ending as we
got into this current ERA of superhero movies and
three what else you might want us to watch hit
that like so we know you liked it that thumbs
up fills me with lots of joy and also thanks
to our folks at prepper who helped this very
video exist if you want to watch this video
and entirety front to back beginning to end
with all of our resting watching faces please
head over to patreon and become a super sexy
reject without further Ado it is time to give to
you superhero movie part two no part one here we
go preparing you for the epicness with this
music the scope of Dimension films oh wow I
didn't know this was diens but makes sense cuz
scary movie right yeah that spoof oh makes sense
too I think uh David Zucker was a producer for
this as well I like the the stainless steel text
too of the era as well it's Saron it's got that
uh Danny Elfman Spider-Man theme feel oh 100%
the I like that we already got to see a
zipper something you never see right dude
written directed by Craig Mason is nuts I know
who am I you sure you want to know the voice of
Spider-Man voicing not Spider-Man actually I'm
worse than a nobody I'm this guy [Laughter] stop
story of my life is not for the faint of heart
it's going to be Spider-Man 2 on overdrive yeah
100% it's all about a girl not that girl it's
about this girl Jill Johnson ever since I can
remember looks familiar I've been in love with
Sarah Paxton oh is that that is a young Sarah
Paxton good call come here man I got your seat
down here what's I call you back baby Kevin har
dude I'm so psyched for this class trip like we
about to see some real serious cutting Ed [__]
that's what I'm talking about he's still like 25
as a high schooler but hey maybe also of the era
I mean that's the thing too A lot of them were
older still in high school yeah the CW was yeah
oh small stuff like that she not even looking
at you she's not looking I already told you
you never going to get with you product placement
it's still true she hangs out with a popular crew
and Nobody messes around outside that group man
look you got your jocks nerds Emos fros yeah how
big this bus is this is great sexual predators
oh my god oh wow of course you got the ri the
who yeah they knew mhm you're the best man am
I in no come on it's me and you baby two of us
against the world you hear me you look good today
I like your here something nasty I download it
don't tell nobody all right little Oz Corb I'm
Dr St head of the research oh they call him Dr
St too and now I'd like to show you our Crown
Jewel The Amalgamated animal genetic SL closest
we'll get to amalgam Universe for another 10
years yeah you're so pretty oh hi birdie take
her picture got to but with a bird she's going
to become bird girl uh I'm I'm going to take a
picture of her for for the school newspaper our
only rules don't feed the animals and please no
flash photography oh my God it flew away this
is one year after order to the Phoenix 2o
is there a problem hey shooter mcavin this is Lou
Landers Visionary scientist
and CEO of Amalgamated Norman
[Music] Osborne are you okay this is healthy
golf blood Rick rker you're not bling Julia
ryker's son are you I am good people how
are they they died violently 9 years ago
but otherwise okay yes thank you I live with
my aunt and uncle now well you seem like a
real chip off the old block let's hope
you're not violently murdered too good
solid advice e that's were making me look stupid
next time I hurt you our work with these animals
has helped us develop new antibiotics and a
powerful new pheromone which drives animals
to mate called compound h29 h29 a single
drop is enough to arouse any animal oh no
breeder powerful phon my most promising
research is with these dragonflies oh he's
dragonfly man this species of dragonfly
has enormous sprank for its size oh God
injected the DNA from all three species into
seven new Genetically Enhanced super dragon
flies there's only six in there well uhoh
this is how it [Music] happens this area oh
God they're all coming for him
now aren't you going to do something
soon as I get this up on YouTube it's
all about the views and the likes that was
the principal Rick walked off a class trip
after all the parenting is this Leslie neelon is
the uncle got to be uncle bed right have no idea
yes taught him everything I know about being a man
and a good man you are after all these years of
marriage your hair is gray you have crows feet it
takes you an hour to pee and you've always had a
tiny
well can't argue
that oh RI we were wondering where you
were o Purity is a difficult time your
mood swings fluid retention and once a
month you'll bleed from your this may be
the wrong book what's important is that you're
on the ver of adulthood here take a [Laughter]
drink I'm losing patience Dr Strong please
sir if you could just hey Homer Simpson
where the board of directors our time
is valuable c not as valuable as mine Mr
Carlson that was great that was my favorite joke
so far yeah oh that was fantastic I did not see
that one coming you didn't see that coming I
have a terminal illness I have 1 hour left to
live it was on sale we can't afford a pet one
a device that can alter DNA and restore the
body to perfect health you're crazy crazy is
hearing voices talking to cats dating Paula
Abdul so the machines never been fully tested
if something should go wrong the machine looks
like he's going to have a labotomy plasma level
steady genetic modifications and Optimum levels
we have to afford so escalated quickly did it
work I'm so sorry what a joy it will be running
this company without you in the way let me go oh
stole his life force he's like vulture in those
early 2000s late '90s Comics yeah gentlemen
I think it's time we made some per Personnel
changes hope data's [Laughter]
okay oh how long was I asleep 5
[Music] days check your ABS that's
the trick did Drake Bell CH train for
this [Music] what's wrong with [Music]
Britney like that was the only
the only option that left him
yet
wait a lot of these characters have uh
their first name and their last name of
the same lighs guess a lot ofation yeah Peter
Parker Jessica Jones comic tradition yeah even
Clark Ked up the letters dad I thought
you oh my god what white supremacist
dad was that's why he was murdered
violently I'm guessing the Girl Next
Door pervert is this a play on is
this the literally the girl next
door I think that was the poster
right the Emil hirs movie [Music]
OHF R I'll be right [Music] down
[Music] yes timing is everything
I am so proud to welcome Dr Steven Hawking
oh oh I know that actor I thought it might
have been Simon Rex I cannot walk and I use
this computer to speak but I am not depressed
because I have the gift of knowledge that's a
lie brutal honesty you can walk talk wipe
your own asses and then there's all the
sex hey anyone want to get high white guy
in the dreads you know what I'm talking
[Music] about I how they just cast a
blonde in their dressing her like G
Stacy like the headband and everything
yeah watch where you're going in slowo
[__] tell her how you feel uh-oh
going to break it off the dragonfly
powers I always love that shot
in ramy's first film yeah the
Spider-Man 2099 kind of power set
ooh damn I'm going to kill you
get yes good Riff on The Flash
Thompson Peter Parker Locker fight
[Applause] [Laughter] slowmo her dad's a teacher
I guess that one guy willing to be shirtless of
those
oh oh oh no time to jump off building oh not
yet now yeah got to climb got to
climb it first [Music] yep [Music]
this is what was missing in ramy's Spider-Man
film Yep this is what they could have
been it's going to be like now
oh my back oh my back he's got to
do Sea Biscuit first ah get out
of the way no breaks oh no look
out [Music] oh like Superman powers
can't believe it you just saved that
old lady's life amazing I I guess if I had
to pushed her out of the way she would have
died you should be really proud
of yourself excuse me it's like
as long as I saved the dog
I don't think I made it in
time whoa how did you do
do that it's easier than it
looks I don't think so why don't you tell
me what's going on he's like take me to the
hospital I think I have superpowers I find
that hard to believe all right how about
this go ahead and throw as many punches as you
want I bet you a hundred bucks you don't land
one I was bitten by a dragonfly
some dragonflies have armored can
I well good thing that worked so you do have
superpowers we can be a team we going to get
fame money don't forget the [__] I didn't
ask for any of this I I just want to be like
everybody else that isn't what your parents wanted
for you you're not my father but I love you like
your father did I had with your mother just
like your father you'll never understand me
[Music] his dad's signant ring I'm guessing
yeah o little Batman Begins M yeah that was 3
years before this yeah yeah something troubling
you it's so unfair does he blame himself I love
that his parents are Batman Bruce Thomas Wayne
and Martha but also The Parkers why did you say
that name give me your wallet Michael Papa John
that's the guy who played the actual guy yeah
and Spider-Man kerine I believe his name was
oh that's so funny you to be a hero when that
day comes will you be ready and he was also an
Amazing Spider-Man as well I love that they
got the same guy back just kill parents yeah
right oh please ah it is actually
his fault oh no that looks like
the same uh in The Mask the same uh
dad oh Rick Alleyway Alleyway yeah
Rick I have something for you reach
into my coat pocket the other coat
pocket that ring was my father's
earn it prick be a hero claim
your this kid is dangerous
a very violent child I'm no
superhero I [Music] don't oh my god did
you hear all that are you okay what you
heard that you're nothing but an ugly ungrateful
little mother who was that my mother my parents
they want me to go to college I want to
be a dancer I believe in you you really
do don't you I wish I could say the same for
Lance am I just dating him to rebel against
my father he doesn't want any Boy near me
that's why he installed the electrified
fence it's funny cuz even with blonde hair she
looks more like the comic Mary Jane than Kirsten
dun like the slight cleft to the chin the Square
Face definitely it's very like Rema Spider-Man
maybe one day you could take me for a ride in
your car uh yeah it's just playing off all the
tropes of Ry Spider-Man Rick this is Xavier TR
your powers are growing but you can't control
it it's important that you train yourself to
fly in your ass because squatting on a glass
table Two Girls One Cup oh no I understood that
reference I need to buy a car frankly Mr rker
you're the worst applicant we've ever had thanks
for the Lo Mr Thompson there must be something I
can do rubbing my under the desk won't change my
mind I'm not rubbing your I really need that car
it was worth a try nobody move everybody
stay down get down come on lady you hurt
o hey made the same mistake I missed
the part where that's my problem you
let him get away with our money I don't
see how that's my problem oh no Les Neil
[Laughter] son I thought something terrible
had happened well I know guy did get shot over
there minimizing the importance of that no one
around him yeah Rick with great power comes great
responsibility I was going to stick with [__]
but I like that one better greate power cubes
[__] oh oh so he's got to
constantly suck the life force out of
people interesting power
hard to be Shooter McGavin
yeah that's going to be a lot of
bodies you're going to have to
hide okay I come back is that Craig Mason
I think that was Craig Mason really I think
that was that would fit like a cameo if you're
writ or director what brought you here today my
uncle your uncle brought you no he he's Gravely
injured well then he shouldn't be driving is my
uncle going to survive well I'm not a bing
man but if you want to put some money on it
I'll take dead in the week first my parents and
now this yes your life has been a testament to
that but your uncle believed in you it's never
too late to become the person you're meant to
be Rick Rick oh here we go how do you know my
name I'm a psychic my name is Professor Xavier
and this is my school I started it to help people
with special talents like yours the students here
learned to harness their incredible talent and
use them to advance the common good some faces
may be familiar like Wolverine yeah most of our
students are born with their powers some like
you gained them later in life came to this
school oh God take enough roid you could do
anything I can't believe he agreed to do that
yeah must have been right as the controversy
you needed the money I mean jeez Professor
about this secret well you see Savor oh
[__] hey a Regina Hall oh man and she was in
Scary Movie yeah inv Anderson s take care of your
man maybe this wouldn't happen oh this [__] is
crazy I'mma have to whip your ass you don't say no
disrespect now what now how about that
invisa [__] invis [__] how could you
do this to me kid how do I know that
baby's even mine because he can do
this I'm never going to know the secret of
becoming a superhero you want to know the secret
Come Close make a costume [__] exactly this is
awesome cuz I always wanted to see Spider-Man go
to Xavier school it's like Ultimate Spider-Man
X-Men crossover yes one day maybe just like
Stanley intended in this spoof wonder if they
ever had him come on to set just for fun I know
he didn't work on this but I mean Hugh Jackman
was supposed to appear in uh in Spider-Man but
they they couldn't get the costume through custom
I did I that I did hear that yes God I would have
freaked out in the theater I literally would
have freaked out in the theater so ahead of
its time yeah oh my God damn that's not bad it's
got the Cyclops but way before Cyclops how can
you see what that I assume it's I breathe too
you put some kind of air intake in The Mask boy
you better dud I'm going tell you something
Rick this is good I'm impressed like really
impressed there we go that makes sense
hey that's my spot you're sitting on
my gargoyle yes Simon Rex what are you
even doing here I'm looking seriously
out over the city that's what I do here
so if you're not moving I guess we're
going to have to share what's your name John
storm so what's your power stand back flame
on I'm on fire not working get the fire
extinguisher oh [__] once you understand
the true nature of heroism you will fly uh
you just collapse into the ground y [__] oh
even better we got our super hero Montage yeah
with newspaper flips yes some time what's his name
bugman a good time in superhero Cinema newspaper
Montage yeah they were didn't expect to Tom Cruz
he's not even a hero I remember this guy I have
I have I have just very early internet before
Tik Tok celebrity he can't even fly the dragon
fly can't even fly I can fly okay this just in
Tom Cruz is dead couldn't fly I'm afraid you
have to kill each day to live each day unless
you had some cerillium take a look Hawkings
lab is in the physics building you're going to
steal cerillium that me someone who will at any
cost survive oh glass in my eye glass in my eye
oh it was called TR Trin or in the Spider-Man 2
right the one that Doc O yeah what was it called
Trum tridium tridium tridium sounds right I don't
remember going to have a jjon to Jameson to
me I want that story on my desk are your oh
there we go I was wondering if you had a
job opening for job how dare you come in
here and ask me for a job I'm the editor and
chief I know the mayor of Venus hamburgers
can see the future Ros sorry about this oh boss
we nowhere on those dragonfly photos those were
tomorrow's lead what about these wow just in his
room it's almost like you're the dragonfly uh no
no no see look just heard on the scanner some
kind of police standoff at Empire University
we'll need photos kid I want you to where'd
he go he's definitely not him no couldn't
be DAV this is the chief of police
we have the building surrounded one
of the coolest voices to ever
voice oh yeah what the hell is
that oh wow that's pretty cool I
Am The Hourglass your time is up
[Music]
s is it I'll fight you to my last breath
un ceasing andless EV will never trium sour
glass be stop stop stop yelling
catchphrases yeah great are you okay
no yeah we got dizzy too from that shot titanium
blades they cut through diamonds I'm not wearing
any [Laughter] Diamonds oh yes this shot that
was from Spider-Man one that was great I wish
I could stay longer dragonfly but I just don't
have the time it's so corny but I love it oh and
that's how he's going to identify the cut just
like Goblin at the Thanksgiving dinner we're
getting Thanksgiving whoever this dragonfly
is he's in over his head we don't need So-Cal
superhero what Empire City needs is more cops
and a Hooters amen Jill I heard your auditioning
for parts so God you are so supportive I can't
Lance be more like you there's something you're
not telling me isn't there there is keep your
identity a secret uh nothing well I should go
tiger uhoh Spider-Man 2 scene wait no where
the rain comes yeah the Street's already wet
yeah seems like again the same Alleyway from
when 100% they probably show it the same day
yeah this is all on universal
Backlot but they're not hiding
[Applause] [Music]
it oh
oh [Music] yes the rain okay we got to
get the upside down kiss how do you get
upside down where are you behind you it's
a fire escape door uh ladder I get to thank
you oh my God
yeah [Music] yeah cuz that's
what happened to kren Dun in
that scene you could clearly see
them in the rain that's so [Music]
funny damn just did the math I'm so Happ oh
here's our Thanksgiving scene yes Thanksgiving
with us of course Lucille we didn't realize how
seasly appropriate this film was yeah all right
seeing my Albert each morning 50 years of marriage
creates quite a bond I wish I knew love like that
oh you will dear they didn't have enough prop
celery to let her cut it so she's just pressing
each of them who can you trust I know but what
if my heart is telling me to be with someone
what what hey babe I forgot to tell you I kind
of invited my uncle your uncle is that another
plate is it well okay I guess Johnson I had
a feeling I was about to say is that where is
Rick what that on I thought he was out I'll
go check on him you're busy allow me thank you
damn yeah I would imagine you'd have
to really go to the restroom after that
Rick going to do the blood dropping but it's
going to be P oh pee you got yeah good call good
call yep yep you go that oh I feel
his pain I've had that happen before
just not on the ceiling or in a super
suit I assume but hey I your [Music]
lifestyle
[Laughter] sprinkler settings is
[Laughter]
great those Elfin swells are great yeah sorry I'm
late oh Mr Landers not to we say grace Jesus amen
I think I've seen a gift of that before of the
stab this I think so Rick has been supporting me
with his new job you didn't tell me I'm sort of
the dragonfly's unofficial photographer uh-oh oh
what happened to your arm a bike messenger knocked
me down I see your wrist is bandaged I bured on
some hot coffee we have to go why I shut my pants
you know the dragonfly I I guess has he ever asked
about me yeah once what did you tell him I told
him the thing about Jill is when you look in her
eyes and she looks back in yours [Music] you if
you were ever lucky enough to be with her you
could earn every second of her [Music] perfect and
her unending ending love don't cry I'm not my eyes
are burning understandable I want you to know that
was the most beautiful thing anyone's ever said to
me God it's understandable after that
turkey she made Rick I'm so confused
and yet somehow somehow I didn't see
that one [Music] coming peeled off the
wallpaper Green Goblin moment hourglass
this is the lair of the dragonfly finish
it this little visit is just to show
you who will get hurt if you get in my
[Music]
way time to
go she can't speak she can't walk she has no
control over her bowels that's that's awful I
know I went ahead and set up a MySpace page for
her under crazy [__] machine Myspace simpler
times yeah in that Facebook Myspace crossover
she's dead truly sorry Rick your uncle came
out of his coma this morning you mustn't
tell him about your aunt just yet he's in
a delicate mental state the slightest bit of
bad news could send him right back into a coma
also to that same year with Iron Man he said I
don't want to see this on your Myspace yeah is
it Lucille no sir it's it's not your dead wife
it's your nephew it's not your dead wife don't
tell him we are gathered today to say goodbye
to Lucille Adams oh instead of Uncle Ben it
was Aunt May yeah we get that seed that way LESA
Nelson's anymore H how could you take her from
me sorry there's been a terrible mistake this is
your wife ah she is this man's wife give me five
[Music]
minutes oh oh I am so sorry for your loss I
know I said some things but we can never be
together you love me Rick I know you do Jill
trust me I'm telling you this for your own
good I don't love you you're no longer in my five
that joke is for a very specific
AG right you're no longer in my
five God look at this place look at
you eating junk food wearing fake
beards I wish I'd never been bitten by
that stupid dragonfly and maybe your
father shouldn't have given you this after all
look at the words your ancestors inscribed in
that ring honor Valor Duty commitment
bravery even if I wanted to stop Stop
The Hourglass I wouldn't know where to start
I mean where's he going to find thousands of
people in one place from the Empire City
Convention Center it's such a Trope seeing
the answer on the news on TV the TV that is
playing what you need yeah the world Humanity
Awards well that shortcut to the
playground sure saved us some
time our first award is for
the medical breakthrough of
the year I have leanders dece bag of the year
[Music] [Applause] [Music]
stop right there Landers you know you're
damn right I do you're the douchebag of
the Year someone in this Auditorium is
The Hourglass I need your help to figure
out who it is did see a man with what
looked like a canister of cerillium who
the dolly
Lama know the world the armor
you're hiding under these Ro
you can't fool me hourglass you're
pecking 10 lb of cerillium under
there oh not Nelson Mandela pleas
[__] all peace until you get hit by a bread
roll [Music] you you're The [Music] Hourglass
did he take her hostage or you'll never get
away with this forget it dragonfly you're too
late ow
oh goodbye little fly oh noly no
[Music] oh dragonfly you must stop
The Hourglass I can't fly if there
is one lesson my life can teach it
is that the spirit is stronger than
the body those are SEL Dion [Music]
lyrics where am I you're with me your
lover what the Spider-Man set with Green Goblin
he's got to like land seated near
there no only now do you [Music]
understand oh
no
oh it's over dragonly chill oh here we go got
you just fall like Rick you didn't think I'd
let anything happened to the girl I love
did you I don't care what happens anymore
if I die I die happily in your arms
you're my hero Rick reer and I love
you yeah because of you our city is safe
at last you said it Dr Hawkins oh no let's
go get some dinner on buying that kind of
reminded me did you see naked gun yeah in
the first one he hit OJ Simpson he went down
uh within the wheelchair will forever be a
[Music] superher oh God we going
to get a mid credits after scene
they weren't as popular but maybe oh
God from the creator of The Last of
Us show and Chernobyl and Chernobyl comes
superhero movie that was quick too pretty
quick I love that Craig Barco got a
wolver in credit for that 30 seconds
yeah what a miles fiser was that guy's name
yeah he was like a the one of the first internet
celebrity like YouTube era impressionist yeah
I remember that but I yeah I just love how this
film just plays off of so many trps and clearly
Ramy Remy Spider-Man was uh the biggest uh thing
that they were going the guy doesn't even name
it's okay I come back Craig B yeah yeah okay
yeah I've seen him in so many interviews with uh
The Last of Us I was like I hope I recognize I
was like Craig Mason um but yeah I just love all
the the superhero tropes that they were playing
off of in this I'm actually surprised it didn't go
uh it did you know touched on X-Men but this was
post Daredevil post Ghost Rider fantastic it did
get Fantastic 4 like a couple you know a little a
little bit there but it was very singularly
Spider-Man yeah blade even too as well and
uh then you had blade one two and three had just
uh 2004 yeah so yeah they didn't really play off
blade but yeah like the Ry Spider-Mans were the
ones that they were but I mean for someone like
me who obviously as everyone always points out
in every video uh loves superhero references I
love all the references that they made in this
film and all the tropes they were going off of
and such a for someone who's such a big fan of
spoofs as well you know from Scary Movie Naked
Gun all those I thought this film just uh I just
I love the humor in this I was surprised to see
it had such a I know films are all subjective I
was surprised to see it had such a low rating on
IMDb I mean it's not the greatest spoof in the
world but it's my type of humor I just uh yeah
I thought it was I thought it was pretty funny
uh what' you think uh I'm not like a spoof guy
I I remember I like the scary movies when I
was younger I have I've risked re-watching
them uh because it's just not like I I really
struggle with comedies like I I personally
think of Comedy as being like Lethal Weapon or in
Brugge or Kiss Kiss Bang Bang like that's comedy
banshees Sharon I like banshees so much that
search light like kept inviting me back cuz I
was basically their laugh track like that's more
my comedy but when I was younger this was more
my like you know sensibility and I definitely
think of scary movie as being like the spoofs
I enjoyed uh I did love Naked Gun as a kid
and there were some moments like especially
the Leslie neelen that that lend itself to it um
but the uh the I think scary movie was definitely
scream Centric but it did seem to Branch out
into more of the topical time of the era oh got
something my dad says my breasts are
too big for a dancer maybe he's right
I mean look at them they're just
Dr talking I'd love to show you
my project on supernovas you have an
incredible astronomy career ahead of
you oh the yes catching in the food tray
yes wait the only CGI in the movie like
or the main what if I killed 28 people in
one session would that give me a month to
live if it were February yes I'll just get to
my back to you but a knockoff you can have it
on the way out Old McDonald had a farm and
Bingo was his name up and uh that's [Music]
uh people thr some crazy douchebag but hit by
a douchebag award and the credits that same guy
who wipes over's ass and I was wondering
what that meant we're a team what do they
call you call me the incredible black in
2003 Mr Landers won the National Science
award for his invention of the non-stick
toilet seat that thing saved my grandma
life excuse me there is a line so
unfair they have nothing why do we
have2 billion I've got tomorrow's editorial
when you sleep with someone you're sleeping
with everyone they ever slept with
does that make you gay yes yes see
die well someone will think twice before they try
to steal a pack of gun from you again
was worth all the damage for [Music]
that dang
[Music] it God weird format at I think that was
about like 8 minutes of credits for an hour and
20 minute movie I wonder if it ran too short to
be a feature length fil yeah cuz usually what they
usually hit the 90 minute Mark right I think 82
is is minimum to be feat right I don't think I've
ever seen that much at the end there like that
where it was like necessary well yeah usually
like in a in a Jackie Chan film you usually see
what like like spoof and and you'll have I mean
you'll have um like bloopers and stuff but it's
usually while the credits are running and then
a little bit that was like a chunk of a good that
was interesting I don't think I've ever seen that
format but I was saying I do think this hits The
Sweet Spot and I do think um what's tricky is the
tone of Comedy shifts uh you know the early 2000s
was like the runchy comedy with your American pies
and your um you know sex comedies and stuff and
the late 200 like as heading into the teens was
like appat was thriving and so like I just don't
think the spoof Market was as strong as it was
in the early ODS like that was I think scary movie
came out in what like 01 uh the first one was 2000
the second one was 2001 so it was like that was
the time they were thriving in those earlies and
this is' 08 this is when things are shifting more
appau this is um you know obviously the superhero
movie stuff's about to go insane yes but uh I
I think that's probably why you were saying you
know like the IMB and stuff were low I think
it's just um you know I again I can I can see
that this isn't my type of Comedy but I can still
see that if it was this would be that but I think
that audience had shifted yeah yeah no for sure I
mean I was into spoof so I don't know why I missed
this one I mean but like you said at in this year
I mean you had Iron Man you had Dark Knight come
out so I surprised I picked those two over this
one but still um choices what were you doing right
I know I missed opportunities but you know I'm
glad I got to react to it with you yeah 15 years
later like it it arrived exactly as it should like
a wizard when it's now a c in cold status but uh I
I do love all like I said all the tropes and stuff
that it played I think one of my favorite tropes
that it played off of amongst many was like that
TV one that was great that's like always something
that's always bothered me in films like I mean
there's so many things in films I'm like that's
perfect timing like usually when someone walks
and when you know someone's about to kiss someone
then the other person walks in or something but
that that TV one when like the the pertinent
information you need to find out we need blah
blah blah oh volume up and it's always a volume
up and you see the volume go up like you see yeah
that's how it works in real life when you need to
know something really important at that specific
time it's really it's right on the TV knew today's
lottery numbers oh exactly exactly uh I also think
they did a good job like it's always so sincere
in movies it was it was really that particular
thing was handled really well here because it
wasn't like as cartoonish as a lot of the other
jokes so it it made you go like well [__] that
is annoying like I like when spoofs do the more
subtle as well as the Absurd like throwing you
know uh what's his name off a building Etc like
yeah um yeah I I like some of the credit jokes
were some of my favorites actually the uh we need
to identify this body that's why it's going to be
so difficult that's such a great that actually is
like a I think of that like a Leslie neelson line
but like well delivered by Tambour but a lot a
lot of the credit stuff was solid um overall had
fun it was great to revisit you know what founded
this genre we love for sure it was great to think
on Spider-Man and X-Men and all those things yeah
fantastic for and uh I mean obviously too like we
said the Remy I would say the first and second
movie were big you know points of interest here
terms of what they were trying to go off of in
terms of the storyline the character stuff uh
yeah tiny bit of Batman Begins which I thought
was great uh obviously fantastic for with our
two cameos finally we got to see Marvel and DC
together guys it's the first time we've seen
Spider-Man at X-Men at Xavier's Mansion yes yes no
that was cool to see that and uh yeah no overall I
I enjoyed this it was fun I actually you know
I thought I mean overall the acting was great
just from everyone it was a really strong cast I
wasn't I did not actually look other than Bell I
didn't really look up the cast I only Drake Bell
because the opening uh like screen yeah but uh
I was uh I was really I was really uh surprised
by how good the acting was because usually with
spoofs it's it can be hit or miss you know uh just
because of the tone and everything with that heart
surprised me which one young Kevin Hart oh yeah
that was Hiser I mean I guess what he was supposed
to be his his har Harry Osborne ask yeah the best
friend yeah um so that wasy I think and no I think
the cousin the girl the boyfriend was probably
the Harry Osborne oh with the flat he was like
FL com they had Norman his be his uncle right
so I think that was kind of like the bully best
friend Rich Kid guess yeah I guess you could call
uh uh Kevin Hart like maybe uh what Ned uh that's
in like the ultimate that's what they've made you
know miles morales's Ganky into Ned yeah um okay
yeah so I guess he would be man Spider-Man didn't
really have a best friend that it was actually his
friend cuz Harry Osborne just kind of used him
well cuz Ned becomes hot in the comics hgin yeah
but like I feel like actually going to school
like no one would ride the bus with Peter yeah
yeah cuz uh you know Harry be taking his Porsche
and then like flash you know hated him until they
got out of high school and they realized you know
the Redemption Arc sorry now I'm thinking about
comic books I'm like wondering who Peter Parker
would have considered his best friend growing up
uh but yeah I I had fun um I'm glad to have now
seen it uh definitely not my general you know
sensibility but like seeing Simon Rex who's like
a classic from Scary Movie again um some of the
Staples having uh Pam Anderson and that uh the
car Electra kind of Ro yeah and again if I had
not seen that Craig Amon had directed this so
confused when never yeah I would not that that
too I would have been like what what is what
is happening but also too at the end seeing
that he wrote and directed it again I still I
still thought it was pretty good but I just I
would have been really shocked to have seen that
even though I was when I saw that before we had
watched it sure but then like actually seeing it
on was like wow that is is surprising I think the
biggest lesson here for everyone at home that
goes blank is making blank oh my God they made
blank maybe you wait and see the movie because if
I was a huge Last of Us fan and I had been like
oh my God the creator of superhero movie is making
Last of Us and I judged it I would have been like
oh but range yeah and evolution it's true true I
mean it's so insane how people judge 100% on the
prior when you like haven't seen the property yeah
I have no idea if they ever made a sequel to this
cuz I know obviously we know they made there's
like five scary movies yeah we know they made
I was just about to say that um but having where
we've uh you know gone into with superhero films
now from where this film was in 2008 I'd love
to see I I mean I I I highly doubt Craig Mason
would want to do this again but um whoever I would
love to see you know them do 15 years later yeah
just I mean because where we again where we're
at today with superhero films I mean there's
been quite an evolution since 2008 I'd love to
see you know um you know not not it doesn't have
to be obviously a Peter Parker Centric film but
just I mean just from they probably go Iron Man
they it today I could yeah I could see I could
definitely see infity Saga te mov yeah you could
do such a riff on the MCU I mean there's so I
mean even even the D you could do something just
making fun of them rushing the DCU I mean there's
there's so much material that you could do with I
mean cuz again like we said the focus here was
clearly on one and two with Spider-Man one and
with Ries so I mean there's just so much material
in there you could even make fun of them doing uh
you know three different Spider-Man at there's
just so much material you could you could even
have them go oh three different people I there's
just so much material you could have in there so
I'd be fascinated if someone would be interested
in doing that and I mean I'd love to see that for
sure and if you liked this I highly recommend
it's on the screen right now watch mysterymen
it is so good I've never seen mystery I think I've
seen one I think I've seen one or two minutes of
that but I've never never I've never SE I think
the only line I've seen is hey maybe you should
put some clothes on if you want to fight crime
like that that's the only line I've I saw it
theaters three times I was like a team superhero
I know Greg can I mean obviously Ben still those
and but I know I've never seen that one I've seen
I've seen blank man though it was one of my first
DVDs I bought with my own money I remember
saving up to buy M DVDs used to be like 28
bucks and I remember like saving for mysterymen
okay I I will check if you guys if you want him
to watch Myster com below yes have you seen Sky
High by the way uh I have I really enjoy I didn't
see it until like three years ago it was a a
great one I love that movie so much Sky High
too I I could see happening it's time but if you
want him to watch mysterymen you want me to watch
uh I don't know there's very few we were talking
before there's very few super movies I hav't seen
I haven't seen punish war zone somehow inex
or League of Extraordinary Gentlemen those my
last two I I haven't seen League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen either if you want us to watch League
of Extraordinary Gentlemen you want him to watch
mrman maybe John hasn't seen it I think GRE has
then let us know in the comments below hit that
like in the way out thank you for being here thank
you to our patrons for watching this front to back
beginning to end thank you to all of reject Nation
again leave a comment leave a like share this Etc
so much love we'll see you soon [Music] Rejects